carson palmer are you back here on the
show i'm here can you hear me
ah literally like you're sitting next to
me
so let's get let's get into that again
because you you you said
at the time that it was all going to
work out uh with brady and erin's this
was back in
in in the off season and now here they
are in the super bowl i give you the
floor on
on on did you even think the super bowl
was possible
for that well i thought i thought it was
possible um
you know at the end of the day brady
left and he just went to the best roster
i mean
he had the opportunity to pick he wasn't
being traded like stafford and golf he
had the opportunity to
find the best roster and the best roster
happened to have one of the
uh the very unique and different coaches
especially different
from a bill belichick's style with bruce
aryan so
i really think it's turned out to be a a
great recipe with with brady and gronk
coming
the weapons they had on offense all the
the draft capital they've had over the
last couple years with levante david and
devon white defensively um the young
winfield corner
uh that's this move to safety uh that's
in his first year
um and then the pass rushers they have
with shaq barrett and jason pierre-paul
it just turned
out to be a a super bowl recipe for
those guys the brady aryan's
relationship
um as you saw it all year long i was
just referring to the
first couple weeks it was like well
aryans are saying stuff publicly that
brady's never
heard from belichick and that might
great against each other how did you see
that playing out
the early parts of all this just exactly
as i expected because i went through it
with bruce
uh in my first couple years you know
that that's what players and his players
respect about him as he doesn't
sugarcoat it he
he tells you like it is and i think you
know you get especially now with
with these kids they're getting
recruited through social media and all
the all the kind of
the pats on the back they get coming up
and then they get the nfl and
you know there's egos involved and and
bruce doesn't care about any of that
bruce will tell you if you're playing
good football he'll tell you if you're
playing bad football he'll tell you
and he won't bite his tongue when he's
asked about it in the media and i think
you know if you have a thin skin that's
going to wear on you but overall i mean
i think
it's a it's a breath of fresh air for
players is just this coach tells it like
it is
he's going to keep it real with me from
day one in the season until the end of
the season
and that's just not the norm nowadays
there's so many coaches that are so
worried about walking on eggshells and
saying the wrong thing and sending up
setting the player off with bruce you
don't have to worry about that he's
going to tell you whether you're playing
good or bad
and like i said he's not going to he's
not going to change his tune when he
gets a microphone in front of him
and then of course you know throughout
the season carson as it was playing out
um
you know the offense did not look
clearly uh as
on point as it has looked over the last
six weeks or so i know you got a life
you got a wife you got kids you're up
there in idaho i don't know how
much you were paying attention to the
bucks you know snap and snap out but was
there a moment where you watched it and
you're like okay
i know this offense i know how it can be
operated and i know brady and i know
that this is
now something they've gotten was there a
moment where you had that
watching them at any point no i i don't
it didn't seem to me from from a viewer
and spectator
that that's what happened um i you know
i'd be surprised if players in that team
said all of a sudden there's a light
switch that went on in week 10
per se um but you know the first couple
weeks this season i was watching and i
was watching
the system they were running a lot of
plays that i used to run and
seeing some of them you know errant
throws that maybe
you know were called aaron by a
commentator but really brady thought
that the receiver was going to break a
little bit higher of an angle and they
came out
flat or vice versa you know those are
just
you know you didn't get a full training
camp you didn't get a whole
otas and a whole off season together
with his new guys
in that new system so there was a lot of
miscues early
which was totally expected um i i think
back to my first couple years with bruce
and in that year year one first half of
the season
there were so many frustrating moments i
think you saw that on brady's face the
frustration with it
it's a simple play it's a simple read
it's a simple throw but if you're not on
the exact same page with that receiver
it's an incomplete pass and that gets
really frustrating especially when it
comes up on third down or inside the red
zone
and those things have been ironed out it
it's not a
you know a month-long process i was i
was being asked about it earlier on the
year i'm like this is not something just
can all of a sudden happen
after the buy this is something that's
gonna that's gonna take the entire
season and
i'll bet you those guys on offense wish
they had three or four more games to
continue to grow together and build what
they've built upon but
um some of those those in you know those
uh
the mishaps early on the incompletions
early on the season were totally
expected
what'd you think of that play call at
the end of the first half in the nfc
championship game what'd you think of
that one
carson i mean that's bruce isn't looking
at the clock he's not looking at the
scoreboard
bruce is not going to play defensively
he's not going to
call plays he you know he this this kind
of new age of coaches these younger
coaches in the league they're so worried
about analytics and
um you know all these different things
and some of these older coaches like
bruce and andy reed man they
they're not going to play defensive
they're playing to win the game they're
going to go get it
they're not going to punt or kick a
field goal in certain situations they're
going to go score
bruce isn't going to play it safe at
that point in the game and run the ball
to set up a nice chip shot field goal
he's going to take your shot if it if
if it's there and brady threw a perfect
ball and um
you know the rest is history that kind
of sent them in into the super bowl
going into halftime with that kind of
play um and sent
the you know the packers into their
their halftime locker room
really reeling you know you get scored
on like that you know
at the very end of the half when you
never expect that play to happen
that's defeating and that was a big part
of the momentum shift that you saw on
that game that sent tampa to the super
bowl uh uh you just hit on something
carson palmer that i i
i love is that these two coaches i mean
obviously so much has been made about
some
coaching decisions in super bowl history
sean payton's
onside kick opened the second half
against the colts
leaps to mind you got both coaches are
going to take that approach i mean
aryans didn't come this far
to do anything but just play it to the
hilt just like he does and
and and you know this this past week
just
i can't wait for america to hear this
guy at the podium last week he came on
the show
uh carson and i asked him hey when you
were quote unquote retired by the
steelers
if i told you that uh this is where you
would be this super sunday
as tom brady's head coach um for the
tampa bay buccaneers this was his
response going what are you smoking bro
give me something that's what he said
carson
yeah you know what when i think back of
my time with him and
just hours hours and hours i sat in
meetings with him
with the receivers in the room the tight
ends the running backs
and and i i wish i was always taking
notes on the x's nose side of it i wish
i would have been taking notes on some
of the quotes he said
because you know a receiver would run
the wrong route or
line up in the wrong spot and if it's a
if it's a
multiple-time offender he would i mean
i i couldn't help it and he's serious
he's not trying to be funny but
i would laugh out loud and then when one
guy laughs in a quiet setting like that
you know you can't keep your mouth shut
so everybody
starts laughing but if i just if i just
would have taken notes
on some of the the one-liners he had to
really make a guy feel terrible about
himself for running the wrong route or
not breaking the huddle the right way or
whatever the situation was
his one-liners just like the one you
played or are fantastic
what do you say when i said how you
feeling he said if i was feeling any
better i'd have to be a twin or
something like that was another line he
dropped i mean
uh he's just all of them he is one of a
kind
um before we get to uh the cbd oil i do
want to hit you
on another subject that's going on right
now um
what advice would you give deshaun
watson as somebody who once upon a time
thought that the situation with the team
that had drafted him was no longer
tenable
for him to play and win what would you
suggest
desean watson do right now carson palmer
well i think you just got to stick to
your guns you know if
if if you or if you're in it to get out
and he has realized that he's got to get
out of there and it's
not you know a winning combination with
his skill set
and the way he leads that team to get to
a super bowl then you gotta stick to
your guns
and and if you said you're demanding a
trade you can't then go back and
renegotiate how it can work out you
gotta stick to your guns
um i i hope that he's got a destination
in mind because
um at the end of the day you know he's
not a free agent he's he's asking to be
traded and so whoever has
um the biggest the biggest price tag as
far as draft capital to give the texans
is where he's going to go so
you know on one side of it you got to
stick to your guns but you also got to
be careful
to you know careful for what you wish
for because houston's not
a bottom tier organization in my opinion
there
there could be worse situations to go
into um and you just hope that if he's
got
two or three teams earmarked that he'd
like to get to and his agent can make
that happen
um that's great and and then houston
also gets a bunch of draft capital and
starts the rebuild process themselves
but there's a couple places that you
don't want to go
that at the end of the day if he demands
the trade and
and they have the most draft capital to
give up it may not be a better situation
so you know
the you know the quote you've probably
heard a million times and bruce has
probably said a million times
there's a reason the grass is greener on
the other side um so you just
you got to be careful there's more
manure over there you got to be careful
where you end up but if it can be one of
the
the places that he's earmarked then
there's no doubt about it he's a super
bowl winning
uh ability and if he if he can get uh
get to the right place be combined with
the right coach the right organization
then that's
that's a player that can win a super
bowl for your franchise no doubt he does
have a no trade clause so he does have
that in his back pocket as he's
demanding the trade
so the question i have for you is when
you were going through it did you ever
think twice like
maybe i i need to figure out how to make
it work here or
like how do you how would you counsel
him about the inner
monologue that he's having well at one
point i knew
a certain team was willing to give up
multiple first-round picks
and when you know
when i was trying to get out of the
bengal situation
they weren't even willing to listen to
the phone call and so that was my
barometer i said you know what if
they're not even willing to listen and
hear the call
then they're not really trying to win
the super bowl and that was my point and
that was why
um i needed a change and so you know i
just think
you know every situation is so unique
and so different
um i i think you know if he if he can
stick to his guns and he's got that no
trade clause then
it really could end up being a great
situation for him to go to a place that
he wants to go to
um that's ready to win a super bowl tell
me about your cbd oil sir that you're
talking about cayden wood and level
select what what uh
what do you like about it what what is
this um yeah level
level select cbd uh you can buy it
online level select cbd.com
um i'm actually up here in idaho i'm
getting ready to get on the river to go
fly fishing
and before i left my house i was moving
up my left knee
i was moving up my right elbow i still
have some some uh
issues and soreness in my elbow for my
playing days and that's my casting elbow
now when i'm casting my fly rod
um so it's it's a product that lets me
continue to do what i want to do and be
outside and be adventurous
and go fishing um go skiing be with my
kids chase my kids around the house i
know you've got
a handful of young ones rich you're
definitely getting up there in your
years
try our level select cbd product okay um
level select cbd.com uh is there a
special
code like uh carson or code palmer for
friends or something like that or yeah
try typing that in
it may not work it may not do anything
just go ahead and type that and see what
happens what is
what is fly fishing with carson palmer
look like walk me through it what do you
got for me
i'm actually i'm actually out here with
my boy philly d aka monkey boy
he's in town he's in town visiting me
he's got all his fly fishing gear on
he's kind of getting pissed he's ready
to get on the water he's wondering why
i'm not
um i'm not hanging up this phone so he's
kind of putting the pressure on me
but it is a beautiful day elkhorn
community misses you right now rich it
is sunny it's a blue bird day
36 degrees which is perfect for fishing
well we're on in boise
um the rich eisen show's on there so
they're hearing it right now and they're
you know they're telling monkey boy back
off
i'm enjoying the conversation with rich
eisen and carson palmer i mean
you know but i don't want to take you
away from it any longer i appreciate the
call carson you are the man
thanks for the two cents love love
talking to you rich as always
best your fam that's uh that's the one
and only carson palmer everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here